so first of all there are indeed some
key similarities between decision trees
and deep learning so for example both
produce input space partitioning and
this partition in both cases adapts to
the data geometry uh but also a few
differences for example a fundamental
one is that if you  have a decision tree
what the functional that you learn is
pacewise
constant and it's discontinuous but if
you have a deep net it will be is fine
and continuous and one impact of this
differ is that deep networks tend to
learn the partition partition regions in
the space  even in parts of the domain
where there is no training samples and
that is really the key difference
between decision trees and deep networks
and that's what enables generalization
and extrapolation basically